Did you know that just this year, paleontologists
have discovered new insights into the behavior
and appearance of Spinosaurus, the biomechanics
of Megaladon shark teeth, and the strangest
early lifeforms of the Cambrian Explosion?
New revelations are occurring all the time
regarding Earth’s distant past, yet these
incredible findings often go unnoticed by
the general public. So, this year, I’m taking
part in PaleoRewind, a breakdown of some of
the most important revelations in the field
of Paleontology from the past year. All sorts
of other creators you might already be subscribed
to are also participating. In this video,
I’ll kick the rewind off by covering findings
from the first half of January — but be
sure to check out everyone else’s entries
too, and the final 2021 compilation video
that will be uploaded on E.D.G.E.’s channel.
Now let’s get started… Beginning in early
January 2021, we have new findings on the
potential ecology and feeding behavior of
the famous theropod ‘Spinosarus.’ The
Spinosarus is a dinosaur that has long gripped
popular culture in its elongated jaws thanks
in part to its appearance in the Jurassic
Park franchise, but the common conception
I grew up with of the Spinosarus as a bigger,
heavier T-Rex analogue isn’t quite accurate.
Indeed, the Spinosaurus has been the subject
of considerable recent debate regarding its
biology and ecology, as it might have been
highly unique from other carnivorous therapods
due to its semi-aquatic or perhaps highly-aquatic
lifestyle. A paper published January 7th by
Dr. David Hone and Dr. Thomas Holtz weighs
the likelihood of a Spinosaurus being a wading
animal that fed on fish near the shorelines
and in shallow water, or a specialized aquatic
pursuit predator. Their studies were quite
complex, but to simplify, based on the anatomy
of the fossils we have and related ecological
data, the wading model is more supported than
the highly-aquatic one. Still, the authors
note Spinosaurus almost certainly fed primarily
from the water and may have swum, which alone
would make it incredibly distinct from most
other large therapods… Our next discovery
exposes new revelations regarding the history
of a highly adapted group of aquatic predators:
sharks. For hundreds of millions of years,
sharks of various sizes have been patrolling
Earth’s oceans. And throughout the Cenozoic,
an extinct family known as ‘megatooth sharks’
started to trend towards gigantism — a trend
that culminated in the well known Megalodon:
the largest marcopredatory shark ever to exist.
This species exceeded lengths of up to 15m
or 50 feet, and likely weighed more than 50
tons. But a mystery has long surrounded the
Megalodon regarding the nature of their teeth.
Compared to the teeth of earlier megatooth
sharks, Megalodon teeth consistently had greater
crown width, for reasons that aren’t entirely
clear. Recently, Dr. Antonio Ballell and Dr.
Humberto Ferrón ran a series of experiments
testing the biomechanics of earlier megatooth
shark teeth compared to the megalodon, and
the results were quite surprising. It seems
stress distribution patterns were remarkably
similar across all models, meaning that the
teeth of Megalodons — while obviously deadly
— weren’t any better adapted than the
teeth of other sharks in their family. It
seems that megalodon teeth shifted in shape
as a by-product of their gigantism, instead
of a specific evolutionary advantage. Still
wouldn’t have been fun to get bitten by
one, though… Winding back the clock by half
a billion years, we reach the Cambrian Explosion,
a metaphorical eruption in the diversity of
early lifeforms, which, as of January 2021,
we have new information on. You might already
know that the Cambrian Explosion gave rise
to countless bizarre lifeforms, many of which
seem more like alien life than something from
Earth’s past. From the surreal Opabinia,
which might have possessed a flexible trunk
that makes it look almost like a living cartoon,
to the Hallucigenia, an animal so dreamlike
its name comes from the word ‘hallucination’
— it’s a fascinating early milestone in
earth’s biodiversity. And a recent examination
by Dr. A.J. Shore and Dr. R. A. Wood unveils
a new addition to this pantheon of oddities.
Through the analysis of some exceptionally
well-preserved fossils, researchers were able
to distinguish a lifeform that possessed a
cup-shaped skeleton with six radially arranged
lobes surrounding what was likely its mouth.
A reconstruction of this lifeform shows it
was a highly unique form of animal, and perhaps
a foundational member of the lophotrochozoan
clade — a group that today includes various
types of cephalopods and mollusks… In the
realm of Paleontology, sometimes seemingly
small discoveries can lead to major revelations.
One article from January 6th shows a curious
potential relationship between herbivorous
dinosaurs and the plants that they ate. A
new examination of fossilized gut contents
by Dr. George Perry suggests plant seeds remained
intact within the stomachs of plant-eating
dinosaurs. Cross-referencing this data with
the distances they likely walked, it seems
possible that herbivorous dinosaurs dispersed
plant seeds far and wide via their, well,
droppings.Strange though this might sound,
some modern plant-munchers — like African
bush elephants — play a similar role in
the, uh, seed dispersal of certain types of
plants. In fact, the dispersal of plant seeds
within the bodies of animals is so frequent
in current ecosystems that plants often modify
their fruits and flowers to appeal to specific
species. And since some dinosaurs could consume
even more plant matter per day than elephants,
it’s likely they were highly sought-after
seed distributers millions of years ago. A
strange, but fascinating discovery… And
our last article covers a whole new taxon
of marine predator, with specialized teeth
unlike those of any known reptile. This new
taxon is a member of the Mosasauridae, a group
of mid-Cretacious lizards that became specialized
for marine life. This exciting new taxon,
called Xenodens calminechari, lived just before
the K-Pg extinction… and stands out from
all other mosasaurids. As reported in the
article by Dr. Nathalie Bardet and Dr. Nicholas
Longrich, this new Mosasaurid possessed teeth
that were hooked and formed a saw-like blade.
The specialized teeth suggests a previously
unknown hunting strategy, likely involving
a cutting motion to carve pieces out of large
prey. Or perhaps these unique teeth were used
for scavenging already deceased marine lifeforms.
In either case, these teeth are unique not
just among mosasaurids, but reptiles in general.
An incredible finding. And those are just
some of the major paleontological revelations
of early January. Special thanks to E.D.G.E.
for inviting me to be a part of PaleoRewind.
Other channels like mine will be releasing
videos covering other months in the coming
days, and I’ll add links to them in the
description when they upload. And Paleo Analysis
is covering the second half of January, so
check out their video next if you want to
go in order. And as always, thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry into the archive
please lend your support, and like, subscribe,
and hit the notification icon to stay up to
date on all things curious. See you in the
next video.